يبدو انه خطه ال الماسك للحد من حالات
انتحال الهويه ما نجحت مثل ما كان متوقع
فماسك طرح اشتراك العلامه الزرقاء بثمانيه
دولارات في الشهر للحفاظ على التوثيق
وكنوع من التحقق من الهويه وحتى قواعد على
تويتر بتمنع حتى انتحال الهويه من قبل
الحسابات اللي بتقلد المشاهير بطريقه
ساخره من دون التنوين بانه هذا حساب ساخر
لكن اللي صار امس ببين العكس ففي شخص
انتحل شخصيه نجم كره السله الامريكي
الحساب والحساب موثق بالعلامه الزرقاء
ومبين انه حسابه نظامي
راحت عملت ضجه كبيره لانه كتب في هذه
التغريده انه بيطلب صفقه جديده رسميه وشكر
نادي اللي هو ليكرز وكتب الى اشياء اكبر
وافضل وادي التغريده قلبت الدنيا وجمهور
كره السله صدقوا انه هذا هو الابراهيم
جيمز لانه خلاص راح يترك النادي وبعدين
طبعا تبين ان الحساب مو حقيقي ومزور
وامتحن شخصيه البرون يعني كل جهود تويتر
وعود ماسك ما مشي حاله لها ويعني صداع
العلامه الزرقاء مستمر يعني لكن ماسك ما
اعتذر وعلى العكس برر اللي صار بطريقه
واقعيه جدا وغرد وقال بما معناه يعني او
انه الكلام اللي قاله قال انه تويتر راح
يعمل كثير من الحماقات الاشهر المقبله
يعني زي اللي بيقول انه ترى احنا بنجرب
اشياء مره لا هنستمر في التغيير وكمان كان
نوع من الدفاع وتاكيد انه خطواته صحيحه
نشر ماسك استطلاع للرئيس 2000 للناس اذا
لاحظوا قله عدد الحسابات الوهميه او
الواتس اللي هي شغله بقى مجننته من قبل
حتى ما يشتري تويتر كانت الاجابات تقريبا
53% قالوا نعم هو 47% قالوا لا
وعلى فكره رغم كل الجدول حول ماسكم مغادره
الناس لتويتر ومقاطعه الشركات وكل هذه
الاشياء اللي جلسه بتصير ما احد بينكر انه
في ناس بيحبوا ماسك جدا ومجانين في فاليوم
كمان تصدر الاخبار عنوان النصب تذكاري
لمسك فمحبين الملياردير الى الماسك من
النقود للعملات المشفره حبوا يهدوه هديه
على طريقتهم الخاصه فاعملوا له نصب تذكاري
طوله بيزيد عن تسعه امتار بقيمه 600,000
دولار ومثل ما شايفين الان في الصور بيظهر
فيها
التمثال راس ماسك مركب على الجسم
كله مصنوع من الالمنيوم مثل ما شايفين على
شكل عملات معدنيه ونشرت احدى معجباته لمس
كل اللي بتعمل في شركه العملات الرقميه اي
جي تي مريم فيديو وتغريده وطلبت من ماسك
انه يستعد لاستقبال هديه في 26 نوفمبر
[موسيقى]